[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous votre 78
est de retour nous sommes le lundi 18
décembre j'espère que vous allez bien
voici le programme de ce soir et si pour
Noël vous offriez un cadeau éthique et
solidaire l'association toute à l'école
qui scolarise des filles issues de
bidonville au Cambodge lance sa boutique
éphémère au centre commercial Westfield
par l vous retrouverez à l'intérieur des
vêtements des accessoires ou encore de
la décoration l'intégralité des
bénéfices sera reversée à la bonne cause
de quoi faire un joli cadeau et une
bonne action un moment de recueillement
à Versailles les chrétiens étaient
nombreux ce weekend pour venir prier
devant les reliques de sainte Thérèse
elles étaient ce weekend à la cathédrale
Saint Louis un moment important pour les
fidèles juste avant Noël comme
d'habitude le lundi votre page sport
dans quelques mois il ne seront pas sous
la pluie comme vous allez le voir sur
ces images mais sous le soleil du désert
Simon et Tangi deux ivelinois originaire
de BI vont participer aux quatre L
Trophy plein phare sur leur préparation
enfin en seconde partie d'émission les
invités du 78 nous parlerons d'un
spectacle qui a pour objectif de casser
les idées reçues sur les des maladies
psychiques le thème de cette année le
bonheur une initiative de l'hôpital de
jour de saincir l'école voilà pour le
programme de ce soir en plateau avec moi
Michel l midoro bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde
journaliste de la rédaction de tv78 vous
allez nous présenter la page sport de
quoi est-ce que vous allez nous parler
ce soir on va parler de plein de choses
he Mathilde ce soir on l'a vu
précédemment on parlera du 4L Trophy qui
s lancera depuis Biaritz en février
prochain nous parlerons également de la
défaite de trappp et nous reviendrons
sur les différents championnats que ce
soit de football de rugby ou bien de
rball ce sera tout à l'heure dans notre
page sport mais tout de suite on va
faire le point avec vous sur les
informations à retenir aujourd'hui dans
les
ivelines et on commence avec cette
informations Jean-Noël barreot et
Aurélien Rousseau étai au centre
hospitalier de Versailles aujourd'hui le
ministre de la santé et le ministre
délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications ont
été présent un an après la cyberattaque
le but féliciter les équipes et
présenter le plan d'investissement pour
sécuriser les données patients et
l'activité médicale direction manie Lamo
une famille a dû quitter son domicile
après avoir subi des menaces de mort
dans la nuit du 8 décembre dernier
pierrelouis Brière a reçu cet appel
anonyme le menaçant de mort l'homme de
30 ans membre du comité citoyen de
manilamo est accusé d'islamophobie après
avoir posé des questions à propos d'un
projet de mosqué une plainte a été
déposée pour menace de mort et alors
est-ce que le maire s'est emparé de
l'affaire le maire de la ville Bertrand
Ouillon appelle à la raison et à
l'apaisement dans un communiqué publié
le 8 décembre dernier à l'attention de
tous les manicoises toutes les
manicoises et manicois viv réaction du
côté des républicains Hutman nasrou
président de la Fédération LR des
ivelines interrogé par le JDD condamne
les faits tout comme Jean-Michel fogous
président de l'aglomération de 50 ans
livivelin également sondé par le JDT de
son côté Valérie pcres demande sur X en
ancien twetter que la famille soit
protégée et que les auteurs soient mis
hors d'état de nuire et du côté du chîné
Roc concours c'est un lycéen qui a été
arrêté après avoir menacé de mort son
professeur de mathématiques ça s'est
passé à l'étilpissement scolair privé à
catholique branche de Castille l'élève
âgé de 16 ans a proféré des menaces de
mort via une publication Instagram dans
laquelle figurait la photo du professeur
une enquête a été ouverte par le parquet
de Versailles l'adolescent a interpellé
le 17 décembre dernier à son domicile et
pour le moment toujours en garde à vue
attention si vous prenez la 14 à partir
d'aujourd'hui et jusqu'à jeudi prochain
l'autoroute est fermé de 22h à 5h du
matin Michel le groupe SANEF a programmé
cette fermeture dans le cadre du projet
de transformation de l'axe
Paris-Normandie en flux libre démarré en
mai 2023 le projet se poursuit avec la
pose de portique sur la 14 et plus
précisément sur la barrière de péage de
Montesson et sur les deux sites du
diffuseur numéro 6a de chamboursy ils
permettront à terme l'ID I ification et
la détection des véhicules dès juin
prochain la 14 sera donc la première
portion de l'axe Paris Normandie à
passer en péage en flux libre dorénavant
à carrière souspoissie les animaux ont
aussi leur cimetière c'est une première
dans les ivlines un colon barium
animalier a été inauguré samedi 16
décembre dans le parc de l'Hôtel de
Ville cet espace dédié éclos de 500 m²
peut accueillir 62 urnes d'animaux de
compagnie les tarifs varient selon la
durée de la concession compté entre 150
et 450 € pour les carrièresrois et le
double pour les nonrésidents un
anniversaire à présent ce weekend
c'était les 30 ans du lycée de Villeroi
à guyencour pour célébrer cet
anniversaire l'établissement accueillé
samedi 16 décembre d'anciens élèves et
professeurs au programme concert
flashmob et rencontre l'occasion unique
de faire un bon dans le temps écoutez le
l'esprit a pas changé parce que
Villarois c'est c'est un esprit de
bonheur de vivre et l'école elle a
besoin de ça aussi j'ai vu des que j'ai
quitté en 2017 sont déjà maman là ça
fait un peu un choc ça a pas changé non
c'est toujours les mêmes couleurs les
mêmes coloris les mêmes emplacement
aussi par que fondamentalement il n'a
pas changé et ça fait bizarre de de
naviguer de revenir dans les couloirs
les escaliers c'est vrai que c'est ça
apporte un moment de nostalgieque ça
fait plaisir ça fait plaisir de revenir
de voir bah que d'autres ont pris notre
place ça fait plaisir aussi de donner
des nouvelles de ce qu'on est devenu et
cetera près de 400 personnes était
présente toute la journée le lycée de
villaroais a été inauguré en
1993 chaque année 800 élèves sont
accueillis pour intégrer l'une des
quatre filières proposées et on termine
avec l'actualité du moment Michell Noël
pour la 2è édition de son marché trappe
à vugrand une dizaine de chalets se sont
installés ce weekend pour une semaine
place de la meurise vous pourrez y
retrouver des produits artisanaux des
décorations des confiseries mais aussi
un stand de jouet à prix symbolique
est-ce qu'il va y avoir des animations
aussi une patinoire a été installée à la
Halle culturelle de la Merise elle sera
ouverte à partir du 20 décembre jusqu'au
5 janvier mais pendant les de semaines
de vacances d'autres activités seront
proposées à la merurise atelier créatif
avec les centres sociaux culturelle
réalité virtuelle avec la cyber base ou
encore atelier ludique avec la maison
des jeux il y en aura pour tous les
goûts Mathilde et bien merci beaucoup
Michel al midoro pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une information ou une
image qui vous a marqué près de chez
vous n'hésitez pas à nous la partager
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78
news la période de Noël c'est l'occasion
de faire davantage de bonnes actions au
centre commercial Westfield par l' de
une boutique éphémère propose des idées
de cadeaux éthique et solidaire jusqu'au
31 décembre c'est une initiative de
l'association toute à l'école qui
scolarise des filles issues de
bidonville au Cambodge l'intégralité des
bénéfices sera ensuite reversée à
l'association Grégory canalé s'est rendu
sur
[Musique]
place des vêtements des accessoir ou
encore de la déco depuis le 1er décembre
une boutique éphémère de 180 m² a ouvert
ses portes dans les allées du centre
commercial Westfield par le 2 son nom
pop ethque by tout à l'école on y trouve
plein d'idées cadeaux pour les fêtes
dont l'intégralité des bénéfices est
reversée à l'association toutes à
l'école c'est une ONG qui scolarise des
petites filles les plus défavorisées du
Cambodge ce sont des petites filles des
bidonville on les prend à la maternelle
et on les accompagne jusqu'à
l'université donc l'idée c'est de leur
transmettre une très très bonne
instruction et puis aussi de les aider
sur un plan médical d'aider les familles
c'est un très très gros campus voilà
donc c'est une aventure sur le long
terme une aventure dont la marine n'est
autre que la journaliste et
présentatrice du JT de 20h de TF1 Anne
cler Coudray au sein de la boutique les
cadeaux proposés sont 100 % éthiques ils
ne font de mal ni à la planète ni aux
humains ni aux animaux une bonne
occasion de faire plaisir tout en
consommant autrement on se demande
toujours quoi choisir et il y a
tellement de choix de cadeau possible
que à un moment donné bah si on se dit
tiens ça a du sens c'est utile c'est
produit en France c'est éthique c'est
bon pour la planète bah ça peut nous
aider à faire notre choix et ça fait
plaisir aussi aux gens à qui on l'offre
et et donc je trouve que c'est c'est
c'est une très bonne idée et puis
c'était bien de s'inscrire aussi au
milieu d'un centre commercial parce
qu'il y a de la place pour tout le monde
desfites sous le signe de la solidarité
c'est ce que propose le centre
commercial Westfield parli 2 tout au
long du mois de décembre c'est étonnant
pour un centre commercial d'accueillir
ce team de boutique aujourd'hui on veut
réellement être des lieux de vie pour
nos visiteurs c'est ceux qui le
recherchent et ce dont on a besoin vous
le voyez également avec la boutique
ressourcerie le petit bazar qu'on a
intégré pour la 3e édition cette année
et qui est situé à l'autre bout du
centre commercial et qui propose des
produits de seconde main popétic by TOS
à l'école sera ouvert jusqu'à la fin du
mois de décembre
la boutique se situe au niveau zéro du
centre commercial installé au chînerau
cancour à Versailles l'heure était à la
prière et au recueillement pour les
catholiques ce weekend les portes de la
cathédrale Saint-Louis étaient grande
ouverte pour venir vénérer les reliques
de sainte Thérèse la religieuse a marqué
la vie de nombreux pèlerins par sa
simplicité le reportage de Grégory
canalé et de Mélanie poket c'est une
première à versaill la petite thérèe a
pu être être vénéré à la cathédrale
Saint-Louis par l'intermédiaire de ses
reliques de sainte- Thérèse sainte-
Thérèse était une jeune normande de la
fin du 19e siècle elle est née en 1873
elle est morte en
1897 et c'était elle a consacré une
grande partie de sa vie à à une vie dans
la prière au Carmel de Lisieux un
message vraiment de confiance dans
l'amour du Seigneur qu'elle cherchait à
vivre d'une manière très simple et très
ordinaire c'est aussi à mon avis pour
cela que elle rejoint beaucoup de
personnes c'est que elle a une vie très
très ordinaire et elle parle à beaucoup
de gens et d'ailleurs ce qui est
frappant c'est que de voir dans la
cathédrale beaucoup de gens viennent
vénérer sain Thérèse la carmélite a
connu une conversion lors d'une nuit de
Noël c'est aussi les 150 ans de sa
naissance une raison de plus pour la
paroisse versaillaise de la célébrer
temps de veiller de prière compte pour
enfants messes ou encore conférence un
programme complet pour lequel les
fidèles ont fait le
[Musique]
déplacement c'était une occasion de
faire un mini pèlerinage puisque nous
surmontons une difficulté de la vie donc
voilà ça nous a permis d'avoir un moment
de recueillement
et de garder confiance et amour comme
sainte Thérèse j'aime bien cette petite
sainte et puis voilà quoi voilà je
compte sur elle pour que pour qu'elle
nous protège ma famille toute ma famille
elle est trité très jeune et que et que
bah c'est c'est la sainte la plus aimé
dans le monde entier je pense c'est un
lieu d'apaisement pour moi donc c'était
plutôt sympa reliqu de sainte- Thérèse
ont aujourd'hui quitté la cité royale la
carmélite poursuit son voyage initié en
1994 allez c'est l'heure à présent de
parler sport dans votre
[Musique]
78 et c'est avec vous Michel midoro on
ouvre cette pageeport avec du football
dans le championnat de R2 mauvaise
opération pour trappe les trappes piste
sont incliné 2 à0 ce dimanche sur leur
pelouse contre Boulogne bienancour une
équipe pourtant à leur pter le FC Manois
s'impose 1-0 à domicile contre
Argenteuil conflan s'impose 2-0 contre
Suren et ardricour perd 3-1 contre
Adamois au classement conflan et 4e
trappe et 6e le FC mentois 7e et
ardricour est 8e on poursuit en football
avec un match à ne pas rater ce soir
dans le championnat de National ce soir
à 21h le FC Versailles 10e reçoit le
leader du championnat le Red Star au
stade jeambois à Paris une victoire de
prestige pourrait permettre au club
yvelinois de grimper au classement le
club versill est actuellement en plein
renouveau depuis le départ de l'urent
pelade et la confirmation de Grégory
vigal comme entraîneur principal les
joueurs de la cité royale sont sur une
dynamique de deux victoires il pourrai
remonter à la 7e place en cas de
victoire on parle de rugby à présent
dans le championnat de fédéral 2 plaisir
se reprend et gagne 24 à 17 face à Ris
Orangis le MLSGP perd 29 à 27 à
l'extérieur sur le terrain du reux et
Versailles a perdu 28 à 16 au stade de
porschefontaine contre Anthony au
classement plaisir remonte à la 3e place
du championnat à 2 points du premier orc
versaill est 10e et le MLSGP est 11e sur
12 Duan bal alors si l'équipe de France
féminine a remporté son 3e titre de
championne du monde hier face à la
Norvège on joué également dans les
championnats locaux dans le championnat
de National 3 le chîn Evelin andb n'a
fait qu'une bouchée de marque à domicile
ils l'ont emporté 37 à 25 face au au 6e
du championnat avec ce résultat le
chînet Evelin est toujours premier du
championnat avec un point d'avance sur
le 2e FB2M la prochaine journée est
programmé le samedi 3 février et on
termine temps du coup il reste un peu de
temps on termine Michell avec une
célèbre course automobile le 4el Trophy
faittera sa 27e édition en 2024 2000
participants prendront le départ depuis
Biaritz le 15 février prochain pour
rejoindre le Maroc parmi les courageux
on retrouvera des ivelinois sur la ligne
de départ Simon et Tangui vont conduire
leurs quatreiles pendant plus de 6000 km
et ils vont traverser trois pays des
images de Julien
Leroi ils ont tous les deux 23 ans ils
sont tous les deux ivelinois et ils
rêvent d'aventure Tangi pichelot et
Simon Bay seront au départ du 4L Trophy
2024 les deux anciens élèves du lycée
blanche dectille du chin et rencour ont
décidé de participer pour la première
fois cette course d'orientation destinée
au 18 28 ans alors le 4 L Trophy on en a
entendu parler euh bah c'est un
événement qui était assez connu dans
notre groupe de potes et qu'on avait
toujours eu un peu envie de faire c'est
juste qu'on s'est dit qu'on le ferait
plutôt quand on commencerait à
travailler plutôt qu'étant étudiant
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de contraintes
avec les examens donc on a décidé de se
lancer là-dedans parce que je savais que
j'allais commencer à travailler bientôt
et que Simon aussi aurait fini ses
études et et aussi parce que on aé que
c'était le moment parfait pour le faire
depuis février dernier Simon et Tangi
mettent tout en œuf pourquoi leur
aventure roule le duo a trouvé sa 4 a
dans le 93 début mai ils ont ensuite
refait le moteur la carrosserie
l'embrayage du véhicule ils vont
maintenant apprendre à maîtriser la
voiture avant que la compétition ne
débute pas si simple pour ces deux novic
on apprend sur le tas on regarde les
tutos sur Youtube et on apprend avec les
mécaniciens qui nous ont aidé à réparer
la voiture donc non ça nous fait pas
trop peur parce que en fait le le
principe du 4 tropi c'est aussi la
solidarité donc c'està dire que dès
qu'on voit un équipage arrêté sur le
bord de la route bah le but c'est
d'aller les aider c'est pas vraiment une
course à proprement parler c'est une
course d'orientation et ce qui compte
c'est vraiment faire le moins de
kilomètr possible en fait sur la
totalité du trajet ce projet de 6500 km
au total est également humanitaire pour
le duo ils vont collecter en amont des
fournitures scolaires en partenariat
avec l'ancien lycée blanche de castillle
pour les distribuer aux enfants le but
en fait c'est d'apporter des fournitures
scolaires aux enfants du désert du sud
marocain à merzuga et en fait bah tout
simplement c'est c'est ce pourquoi on
voulait le faire c'est c'est une visé
humanitaire aider les autres quelque
chose qui a du sens et qui est concret
surtout pour nous parce qu'on va
vraiment distribuer des fures scolaires
pour que les enfants de du désert
travaillent dans les meilleures
conditions possibles tout simplement les
deux ivelinois prendront la route au
volant de leur 4 le 12 février prochain
direction biarit les étapes de
vérification le grand départ et lu
programmé le 15 février au total il
traverseront TR pays en 10
jours merci beaucoup Michel midoro pour
toutes ces actualités sportives on vous
retrouve du coup à la rentrée en janvier
je serai là en 2024 merci Michel est-ce
que vous avez fini vos cadeaux de Noël
j'avoue qu'il m'en reste encore deux ou
tr acheter il faut pas le dire mais mais
voilà ça ça devrait se faire dans les
deux trois prochains jours normalement
en tout cas pour ceux qui n'ont pas
encore fini leurs cadeau ou qui n'ont
pas commencé la rédaction de TV 78 vous
donne tous les jours une idée de cadeau
yvelinoise si vous nous suivez sur les
réseaux sociaux vous avez sans doute vu
passer notre calendrier de l'avant
producteurs locaux patrimoine ou encore
expérience à découvrir dans le
département je vous propose qu'on ouvre
ensemble la case d'aujourd'hui envie
d'une pause détente pour le calendrier
100 % evelinois je vous propose de
relâcher votre esprit et votre corps au
spa Calicéo de saincir
[Musique]
l'école c'est le plus grand espace
bien-être d'île-de-fance donc autant
vous dire que vous avez l'embarras du
choix à partir de 26 € vous pourrez
profiter des différents bains à 34° du
sauna et du hamam si vous préférez les
massages les soins ou autres rituels
faites une pause au spa à partir de 61
€. et pour les plus sportifs des cours
animés sont proposés toute l'année
aquabike aqua gym aquaraining il y en a
pour tous les goûts comptez 150 € pour
une dizaine de séances et n'oubliez pas
Pierre de Coubertin disait un esprit
saint dans un corps saint alors
n'hésitez
pas un esprit saint dans un corps saint
mais on a surtout bien besoin de se
détendre avant les fêtes de fin d'année
c'est bientôt l'heure des invités du 78
mais avant je vous propose de jeter un
coup d'œil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin nous devrions avoir la tête
dans les nuages sur l'ensemble du
département côté température il fera
assez froid compteter 6°gr à montte la
jolie et 4°gr à houdans rambouillé et
versaill l'après-midi le ciel sera
toujours très nuageux dans les ivelines
le brouillard sera persistant dans le
secteur de rambouillé niveau température
il fera 10°g à Mantel jolie et Houdan
8°g Versailles et 7°gr à rambouiller et
demain nous fêterons la sain urbain
c'est l'heure à présent de passer aux
invités du
[Musique]
78 et ce soir avec les invités du 78
nous allons parler d'un spectacle dans 2
jours le groupe commun accord sera sur
la scène du Théâtre Gérard Philippe à
saincir l'école pour en parler avec avec
nous Hélène Goupil bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous êtes infirmière à l'hôpital de jour
de saint-cy et Valérien moulera bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes un usagé de l'hôpital
de jour alors dans un premier temps
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
qu'est commun accord comment est né le
groupe euh comme un accord il est né
suite à une
rencontre d'un usager qui est venu en
soin à l'hôpital de jour et c'est un
guitariste musicien voilà qui qui a une
cinquantaine d'années mais qui a
longtemps pratiqué la la guitare
et du coup pour l'accompagner dans ses
soins et ne pas tout le temps évoquer la
maladie on a commencé enfin j'ai
commencé à l'accueillir avec sa musique
et et au gré du temps et des rencontres
voilà il s dit bah c'est bien de jouer
de la musique mais mais pas tout seul
j'ai envie de faire participer d'autres
personnes avec d'autres musiciens voilà
et c'est comme ça qui est né le groupe
comme un accord et après il y a eu
l'envie aussi de partager ce qui était
créé tous ensemble avec un public et du
coup on a donné notre premier concert il
y a il y a 3 ans 3 ans c'est pour ça que
vous ouvrez aussi le spectacle à tout le
monde tout le me le le projet évolue au
fur et à mesure du temps et ce qui est
important enfin moi après j'ai ma
casquette toujours d'infirmière porteuse
de projet et puis qui accompagne les
usagers et je suis pas toute seule j'ai
aussi toute l'équipe avec qui je
travaille tous les soutiens au niveau de
voilà des hiérarchie l'institution qui
nous permettent aussi de pouvoir faire
vivre ce groupe mais l'idée l'objectif
c'est vraiment de de faire changer les
regards sur le handicap psychique
et dire regardez on est là il y a des
personnes qu'on voilà qu' on des
troubles psychiatriques
mais faut pas regarder que ça il y a
plein de compétences et on s'appuie sur
ces compétences là et vous Valérien
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez décidé de
rejoindre le groupe comment accord ben
en fait ça ça faisait longtemps que
j'avais pas joué dans dans l'instrument
de musique en
fait j'ai pris des donc moi je joue
cophone dans le Grou et ça faisait
quelques années que j'avais plus touché
au au saclophone mais j'ai toujours
gardé cette passion pour la musique et
en fait justement quand quand les
infirmères de l'hôpital de jour on
parlait de d'un groupe de musique bah du
coup ça m' ça m'a tout de suite tout de
suite intrigué j'é en train de me dire
un groupe de musique ça pourrait être
pas mal de bah de voir qu'est-ce qu'ils
font donc que je je Allis une première
fois accompagné de ma mère voir voir le
groupe j'ai pas resté très longtemps
parce que c'était j'étais un peu
intimidé quand même un peu intimidé par
les gens
euh parce que c'est une quinzaine de
personnes maintenant le ouais sur sur
scène là mercredi il y a ouais une bonne
quinzaine de personnes euh pour ce
projet nouveau on l'a partagé avec un
autre hôpital de jour le centre jeène
bleuir de versaill qui eux donc on là
vont faire la peinture sur scène voilà
on essaie de il a pas uniquement de la
musique en fait c'est a aussi prestation
de peinture ouais
on jusqu'à présent de petit à petit le
le dessin rentre en scène voilà au
dernier concert il avait une exposition
de dessin c'est assez original comme
concept original je crois qu'on on reste
ouvert aux propositions et on voit enfin
vraiment c'est une aventure collective
c'est du coup on essaie de de
coconstruire ensemble le projet et après
on a aussi un musicien professionnel qui
nous accompagne et qui là en septembre
nous a dit bon ça va là jouer de la
musique vous savez faire voilà on va
essayer de voir un peu plus plus grand
et on va monter un spectacle voilà et
Valérien pourquoi c'était important pour
vous de monter sur scène de réaliser ce
spectacle avec tout le monde et ben bah
déjà il y a le plaisir de de de jouer de
un instrument de nouveau déjà de de le
faire avec avec un groupe aussi d'avoir
bah des des camarades en fait
c'est parce que c'est une petite
communauté oui c'est une petite
communauté
pu tout le monde tout le monde est
bienveillant dans le GR dans le groupe
donc il y a aucun jugement il y a au
aucun mot de travers ou insultant ou
même aressant il il a rien tout ça il y
a vraiment un esprit de groupe et chacun
se soutient mutuellement en fait
on travaille pas juste tout dans le on
travaille vraiment tous tous ensemble
même si il a aussi une part aussi sol de
travaill chez
soi c'est vraiment l'ensemble qui compte
et cette année vous avez choisi le
bonheur comme thème pourquoi parce que
je pense qu'on a tous un peu de bonheur
à
partager autres ce genre de chose c'est
une thématique qui est revenue sur
l'ensemble du groupe accord tout le
monde avait envie de parler du bonheur
cette année oui je pense on parle du
bonheur et aussi on s'est en
réfléchissant à cette thématique pour
éprouver le bonheur aussi bah il y a des
fois on passe par des moments qui sont
moins qui sont moins gay
qui voilà avec la maladie psychique ou
ou sans maladie he on peut vivre des
moments angoissants stressants tout ça
et du coup ça nous permet aussi de de
savourer les moments où ça va où on
éprouve de la joie tout ça donc il y a
eu tout un travail euh de
réflexion autour de bah la thématique du
bonheur et ce qui fait moins le bonheur
et ce qui nous fait du bien et puis
aussi de réfléchir à
à c'est quoi c'est quoi ces petits
moments de bonheur et de pas forcément
attendre des des grands moments
d'explosion de joie et des fois ça peut
être simple euh et je pense que le fait
aussi de d'être tous ensemble de
partager ensemble de coconstruire
ensemble bah ça contribue à à se sentir
bien et voilà je pense que ce qu'on va
essayer de de faire ressentir à notre
public mercredi en tout cas sur la fiche
on a vu vous vous questionnez il est où
le bonheur je pense que au sein de ce
groupe commun accord vous l'avez trouvé
finalement en tout cas quand on on
partage la musique ensemble oui je pense
que c'est un très bon c'est un très bon
moment à chaque fois c'est et puis ça
fait 3 ans c'est ça devient un
rendez-vous important j'ai l'impression
c'est euh oui alors
après comment dire quand on participe au
groupe il y a voilà ça fa fait 3 ans
qu'on existe mais il y a des gens qui
sont restés une année 2 ans enfin voilà
il y a rien de c'est comme la vie on
prend ce qui vient sur ce dont on est en
possibilité
d'investir voilà on retient pas les gens
c'est pas l'idée l'idée c'est vraiment
de de faire vivre des des expériences
comme va le vivre Valérien il il est
rentré dans le groupe au mois de mai
l'année dernière d'accord donc c'est
c'est tout neuf nous on est super
content de son investissement et de
toutes ses capacités qui retrouve
de on en parlait tout à l'heure notre
chef d'orchestre quand il qui lui dit
solo euh voilà ça fait un peu peur mais
il y va et voilà j'essaie vraiment de me
donner à fond même si même si j'ai pas
l'habitude ça permet de prendre
confiance en soi ou voilà et tout ça
tout ce bagage là qui viennent
expérimenter
euh faut voilà l'idée c'est de
l'utiliser pour pour la suite alors il y
aura de la musique des peintres il va
durer combien de temps ce spectacle
environ au dernière répète on était sur
une bonne heure une bonne heure une
heure vous êtes fin prêt c'est mercredi
on a on a vraiment la touche finale
demain justement pour pour bien que tout
soit bien carré comme il faut pour
mercredi mais je pense qu'on peut partir
optimiste et bien merci beaucoup Hélène
Goupil et Valérien moulera d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau
alors si vous êtes intéressé le
spectacle de commun accord il est où le
bonheur c'est ce mercredi 20 décembre à
14h30 au re Gérard Philippe 2 saint-cir
l'école l'entrée est gratuite et c'est
la fin de cette émission merci pour
votre fidélité je vous donne rendez-vous
demain soir pour une émission spéciale
Noël en attendant je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur tv78 prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous